because i i can't direct the
conversation if i don't know
in and out the the technical limits of
the product
and what can be scaled and what can't um
and also i need to understand who i'm
talking to so if i'm talking to a vp or
an analyst or
or you know um investment relations
person it's a different type of
conversation so i need to know what
makes them tick
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
today we're going to talk all about
solutions engineering what is it about
and why is it so much fun meet
invalshalev
the head of solution engineering of
placer ai she is a creative solution
oriented analytic expert
and experienced in technology and
intelligence environment she has
performed across the life cycle from
requirements analysis to solution design
and implementation
with hands-on experience in data
analytics and big data applications
she has a passion to bridge between end
users and development teams
technology-oriented intelligence officer
she was a cabal
with vast team leader experience in
balsa lev welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
i'm doing great it's a nice sunny
morning here in
tel aviv you're in the placer ai offices
right
right right there we're sitting in the
bullseye now
um it's fairly crowded it's it's been a
while since it was that crowded so
we're now after our round b and starting
recruiting so
it's a it's a hustle here yeah yep so
you know all over the israeli news
recently raised over 50 million dollars
in your in your round b
and you're in solutions engineering and
so we're going to talk soon
about that and your role within placer
ai but before we do that i'd love to
get a little bit of context both about
your own journey and and how
how you look at your own career but also
a little bit about placer ai just for
the context of where you work
great so placer is doing location
analytics
and location intelligence we are
we are partnering with mobile apps and
basically integrating location data of
users
it's fully fully private we're not
sharing any information
about the about specific devices but we
take
we take the location data of over 30
million devices in the us
so we have around 10 percent of the u.s
population which is a great
great sample and we then
yes it's big and we're able to estimate
how how many visits they did to various
locations
so it's very much like an election poll
you have a sample you know how how
much each panelist represents of the
population
and then you can give amazing reports
you know to show
all of historical foot traffic to a
certain a shopping center or a walmart
and and that information is super
valuable
we're catering basically to um
commercial real estate brokers as well
as
hedge funds retailers we have amazing
clients
you know from a dollar general
and target and to to hedge funds and cpg
companies
wow and and so what is that so what does
head of solution engineering
do in that in a world like that what is
even solution engineering before we ask
what does the head of it do
so the way the way i describe it is
we are kind of the mitigator we're the
proxy between
between the client needs and the
technical
the technical requirements and the
um basically uh limitations right
we're still trying to to cater to our
customers and
and be flexible with with the startup
startup mode and we are constantly
looking
at at innovation so a lot of the time
the product is defined to answer certain
business questions
but then a new client comes in and asks
for things that
we didn't think of and then we either
provide it as a
custom report or um add more
requirements to the to the product
and we're there to to help help out in
these cases in these edge cases
where they're either product gaps or
some kind of risky situation with
sales and customer success
can you walk me through you know even a
case study or some
more tangible example of how what does a
solution engineer actually do within
within an organization where where is
the solution engineer coming into place
because it sounds from what you're
describing that
you're not necessarily involved in every
you know every development operation and
every feature that is being requested
and there is sort of this you know
interesting gray area where
a solutions engineer can come and help
mitigate a lot of this dialogue
right so um in many
in many companies solutions engineering
are helping the sales team
to to build decks and to build use cases
to help sell
um that's that's one piece of solutions
the in placer it's a bit different
because there are
also we have an amazing sales team
that's highly proficient and the product
is amazing you only
you get a demo on and and usually um the
use cases are there
and what i am pulled in to do is is
these more advanced
questions advanced needs it can be uh
interaction with a data science team
and and then you know the technical
conversation is a bit a bit deeper right
it can be defining a new defining a new
vertical
right so for example of our first
airports
that came in we didn't know what we have
to offer and
what's going to help them out so i was
involved in that situation to understand
if our solution is good enough what's
our limitation
how we can make sure that we're
onboarding them and and you know
not overloading our system and still
creating value for them
and so what is what is the day-to-day of
this of this job look like so
it sounds like you're working both with
the clients you're working both with
engineering teams
you're doing also research in between
how does it actually operate
it's a great question i think it's it's
one of the most centric
i think i'm working with the most amount
of teams in the company
so on on one side i'm client facing so
i'm working with
the the sales team and the customer
success team
in front of prospects and customers
and that is looking at those edge cases
that we discussed
but on the other side it's um it's
discussing with uh with the product team
understanding how our roadmap
looks like how we can incorporate or
push in a bit
like more small stones that can be great
wins with clients and prospects
that will help sell more and help raise
client satisfaction
it's also working with the data
analytics team so um
that define and design piece making sure
that
that what we're actually doing is
answering the use case of the client
and i think you know that that requires
a lot of
a lot of technical understanding in
addition to
knowing how to package it all and frame
it
in a client-facing way now
it sounds to me like what in what you
mentioned before
this idea of solutions engineering is
not yet a very common one or is not a
very
well known one for people that are
looking to decide what they want to do
you know whether they want to be
right certain researchers and engineers
product managers
why why do you think that is and what
what type of personality
do you think fits the solutions
engineering role
yeah it's um i i wasn't aware of this
type of role
um until the last let's say three years
i didn't even know it exists um
and to your question i think it
it requires both highly
highly um highly technical understanding
so it's
it can't be like a first position it can
be someone straight out of the school
and why not so what about this job
requires that extra experience
so in the on the analytics side
you you need to see a few things that
you know you need to be around to
understand what works and what doesn't
and you have to experience some
success and failures in my opinion i i
don't hire any
anyone to this position that's in that's
his first job
um but it can come from many places i
have
solutions engineering that came from
product that came from
consulting that came from data analytics
that's
that's all valid but it needs to be a
person that has that
um that creative mindset i think that's
the point you know you need to
you need to see uh to be able to
kind of pull out information from from
who you're talking to
understand where you want to lead the
conversation and it's
it's a it's a lot of soft skills a lot
of
a lot of soft skills and a lot of based
on a lot of
technical knowledge because i i can't
direct the conversation if i don't know
in and out then the technical limits of
the product
and what can be scaled and what can't um
and also i need to understand who i'm
talking to so if i'm talking to a vp or
an
analyst or or you know um investment
relations person it's a different type
of conversation so i need to know what
makes them tick
um and and help help them solve their
their use case help them
reach success with our data right
and so one of the things that we we
talked about before we started this was
pretty much how much you're enjoying
what you're doing and finding you know
the happiness and the satisfaction with
with the everyday position and i
mentioned that you know
this is a fascinating topic because you
know what i'm saying around me and a lot
of people
you know we we we tend to run so fast
and we we rush towards
you know things and we sometimes we
forget to stop and and enjoy the work
that we're actually doing
and so tell me a little bit about your
experience either with place or with
solutions engineering and what what
satisfaction it brings you
yeah that's a great question i think i
think what i love about this position
and
is that it's never boring right it's
like
it's never repetitive i am i am
i'm meeting new people and new types of
challenges every day um it's not for
everyone right
some people need their routine and need
to have a very clear
clear defined goals but i like the
action i
i'm an adrenaline junkie i i need it
right
so so for me it's fun it's fun to get in
a conversation and i don't know how i'll
get out of it
um i i don't know where it's going to
lead me but
but i'm excited about that relationship
and
what we can make and you know
and coming into it with a smile i think
it's one of the best
advices i got right it's all about the
communication and people relationship
and
so i think that's what's most fun for me
that
interaction and that um
ingenuity and innovation in each
relationship
so i need to i need to get my brain
going with each
which each discussion
right and so do you ever feel like you
know
almost an outsider to an organization if
you're if what i'm hearing correctly
that you are sort of this connector
between a lot of different moving pieces
within the organization but also
with one leg outside of the organization
because at the end you're bringing those
solutions those
so there must be times when you're you
you might have an idea that is maybe
not exactly what some of the engineering
teams thought or what some of the
clients thought
and you still have to sort of connect
those gaps and and find a common ground
that that doesn't seem like an easy
thing to do
okay you're still right you know that's
and i think
the fact that i'm situated in israel
with the team
makes it so much easier because i've
been in organizations
where the solutions engineering team was
based in another state
away from that engineering side and and
it makes all the difference in my
opinion because before i
before i promise something i go and i
speak to our
to email our data analytics lead i'm
talking to the product i'm making sure
that
we're all aligned um and and not uh
and i don't put this the company in the
situation or the people in the situation
they don't want to be within
and but you know it's it's very easy
in in organizations to to use
authority and i don't believe in that i
believe in in you know
a partnership communication and and
having that damn
that open discussion before we reach a
decision and do it together
so sometimes i feel like an outsider but
i'm also
um i'm using my my skills to
to make it to to create partnerships
with
with the engineering team with the
product team with analytics team
so that um they like helping me they
want to help me and they see that
that success later on and they're happy
about it they're excited about it and
we're creating that excitement
internally
now when you look at the team that
you're leading wha what does this
sort of internal training look like so
how do how do you actually
support the people that are working with
you and and helping them become better
or training this mindset because it
sounds like this is
you know a lot of these skills that
you're mentioning these are not skills
that you just gained from academia or
from
necessarily previous experiences you
have to live through that
indeed yes so we are because we need
combined skills i'm combining a lot of
the trainings of other teams
so the team is going through
many many types of of training with the
support team
so actually hands-on creations of
locations looking at
the under the hood how how all that
system works how we're combining those
the foot traffic and the location um so
support and then data analytics um
going and having even a day with each
team
to to get to know them and also to to
understand what types of
of reporting they're they're currently
doing
and a lot of shadowing with me and with
the team
the the customer success and the sales
team there is
at least 10 calls with the with sales
and with customer success
before and before we are even starting
to talk about
their own projects so and then you know
ongoing projects to to create that skill
set
i'm also really really important for me
to have people that can
play with data and understand it so my
requirements are
as a baseline to have some kind of
coding language and vi tools
proficiency and so
when you actually go through and how do
you actually have
every person running different you know
different projects
different features different
integrations are you working as a team
on each of them how does it actually
work
yeah because because it's so important
to create um
a relationship in this type of role we
are assigning
to each um to each solutions engineer
a few accounts that are strategic that
he's joining and you know making sure
it's
they're on the right track uh those are
a lot of time
high high demand ones right so they're
helping out and making sure
we're getting to a successful engagement
yes and it's an ongoing game
relationship building so yes everyone is
assigned to different projects
um but we we we have a lot of
sales engagements as well and that's
like quick in and outs
i see and so do you do you think that
the
solutions engineering that you're
experiencing at placer is this
you know what is happening you know
around the ecosystem around
solutions engineering is this something
that has been going on for a while
because i i also i haven't really heard
about
solutions engineering pretty much until
this conversation
yeah it's it's been you know for me it
was in my last position
i was a head of data analytics
and and i was managing tons of people i
was
i had 40 people in three different
states and
you know as a manager what i used to to
do is is get that um requirements from
um from a new account and and deliver on
it
and then when i i started an engagement
i then
understood that they they miscalculated
the effort completely
right um we might have sold it for for x
but you know had to invest
invest 2x in terms of of their money to
deliver
right and then we're in a loss
and and i found myself because i was
getting getting more and more involved
in these in
these spaces of um estimations versus a
reality i i found myself more and more
engaged with the
with the sales process with with that
onboarding
piece and and i found that
there is a big disconnect a big
disconnect between
what we are uh what we're selling what
we're expecting
and what's happening on the ground and
i i did find myself very very passionate
in help
in helping and to to mitigate that gap
uh and set right expectation because you
know
at the end of the day what do you do in
that scenario you either
reduce the content and then the the
end result is an unhappy client that is
not getting what he paid for
or you are putting in much more effort
and then you're in a losing position
so i think in many cases that's the
that's the the
that's what's happening because
solutions are usually
on the sales and business side
not very connected to the to the r d
product and and that that side of the um
that side of the world of the company
world
so i think and of course it's not like
that in
in every company that's just my personal
experience
i think when it works good there is good
connection
and and that's a that's a team that
helps reduce
friction and helps them really
really create success with complex
accounts and complex deals
right now that makes a lot of sense and
and in ballet you know i thank you for
introducing me to this world
it was it was really you know
interesting for me to to get into the
mind of
of a solutions engineer and and find a
new you know a new vertical that i that
i didn't really think too much about
before this conversation so thank you
for your time
i have a few questions about you and
baal not not about place or not about
solutions engineering and i want you to
go back you know take me back to your
childhood and
tell me what what fascinated you as a
kid what is perhaps a subject in school
or a passion hobby
that really fascinated you
yeah i think i am i've always been
i am a very creative person um
i was always painting since i remember
myself
so that that was that the part that i
was
most most
connected to i love paintings i love
everything that's plastic art
uh yeah that's that's my that's my love
amazing and
one of your inspirations along the way
somebody a role model or somebody that
inspires you
in some way shape or form
so the the thing i'm it's not a it is a
real person
but there is this book that was really
that really inspired me as
a child um it's called butterfly
i don't know if you are familiar with
that
but it's about a french prisoner that
was accused by
a with a crime with a murder that he
didn't commit
and he was sent to to french's um
colonies in in africa and
and the whole story it's a real story
there is also a movie about it
um and that the whole story was about
his
um he was running away from prisons for
about
like three four times and and that
really hit me as like the human
nature of survival and your your your
drive for freedom
so i think that's a great inspiration
for me yeah
butterfly that person yeah very very
cool
and what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself
so i would say um creative
of course repeating the subject here
i would say that i'm friendly
and smart thank you very very much
and this was a lot of fun thank you for
sharing this time with me and
best of luck with placer it sounds like
you're doing amazing things thank you
thank you thank you for the time bye